hey everyone so I've got a book coming
out later this month you can check it
out or pre-order it in the description
below thanks to all of you who have
pre-ordered it already hi welcome to
another cold fusion video there's
something big happening in China right
now technology is being used like never
before to mold a society in this episode
we'll see exactly what's going on inside
the closed doors of China buckle up for
a wild ride on March 11th 2018 two
thousand nine hundred sixty four
delegates walked into the Great Hall of
the People in Beijing at the annual
meeting of the National People's
Congress a staggering ninety-nine point
eight percent of them voted to abolish
the legislation in China's Constitution
which limits the sitting president to
serve two terms this allows for the
current President Xi Jinping to rule
indefinitely this overwhelming 99.8%
vote is an example of the control that
one man and his party have on China but
the government itself isn't the only
thing under tight control in China so is
the public and Technology plays a big
part
[Music]
we chat a Chinese messaging service
scored a zero out of 100 by a mustiness
no for security concluding that we chat
is subject to both quote censorship and
surveillance WeChat has over 1 billion
users with 500 million users in China
there's equates to just over 1 in 3
people in China using the app WeChat
even admits that it releases personal
data used through the app to the Chinese
government in compliance with quote
applicable laws or regulations but the
thing is we chat isn't just a messaging
app it serves email banking it's also a
social platform you can order taxis pay
electricity bills
and much more without ever leaving the
app so basically one in three Chinese
500 million people use WeChat for
everything and the Chinese government
can see it all so what does the
government do with all of this data
well cases are hard to come by in a
country which has the persistent
suppression of media however the
implications are massive from censorship
to deterring anti-government protests to
using the heatmap feature which tracks
all of the users GPS locations the
Chinese government can benefit an
enormous amount by this vast array of
information as the proverb goes
knowledge is power
Chinese hardware companies such as
Huawei and ZTE have fallen under
suspicion this is because the Chinese
government has the ability to request
use information from any Chinese company
the same way they do with WeChat and
while some experts say that this
wouldn't affect the average person the
seriousness of China's potential tease
this Hardware for its own purposes was
highlighted in early 2018 six major US
intelligence agencies including the FBI
NSA and CIA unanimously agreed the
private US citizens are not advised to
use Huawei or ZT products it's not like
these agencies have the best track
record themselves do you think they're
telling the truth or a lying or do you
think that the truth is somewhere in the
middle I'll put up a live poll here
so why can't Chinese people just not buy
a mobile device or an app made by a
Chinese company in reality it's easier
said than done even if you boycott it
using a phone the Chinese government's
monitoring goes way beyond the devices
in your hand there are 200 million
surveillance cameras in use in China
approximately one for every seven people
in early 2018
these cameras even entered the classroom
to monitor the facial expressions and
attentiveness of students since 2015
China has embarked on a project to
create the most powerful facial
recognition system ever seen with the
goals to recognize 90% of citizens
within 3 seconds of recording while it
hasn't reached these levels yet it's
been used to catch jaywalkers unlicensed
drivers and pick out wanted fugitives in
crowds the government uses facial
recognition along with an outdoor screen
to shame jaywalkers by posting their
government ID on the screen after
they've jaywalked the intent is to shame
individuals as their friends family and
coworkers will be able to see their
faces on the screen much like some
restaurants pin up photos of customers
who have died without pain
the idea of shaming people into
conforming is not an isolated incident
in China the Chinese government
introduced a social credit system which
has been tested on 6% of the population
currently it is anticipated to be
completely in place by 2020 now if
you've seen the black mirror episode
nosedive you know that it's about a
world where a universal Social Credit
system allows people to rate others
depending on even the smallest social
interactions the score determines your
service for flights what home loans to
get offered what car you can rent etc in
the black mirror episode the result was
that everyone's interactions ended up
being fake and two-faced and the system
changed the behavior of society in a
fundamental way this is essentially
what's happening in China down to the
security of lions and being allowed to
board flights it's eerily similar to
Black Mirror in 2018 a list of 169
severely discredited people was released
by the Chinese government the people on
the list were subsequently banned from
taking flights or trains for a full year
further a total nine million people
would low credit scores have been barred
from buying airline tickets or
first-class train tickets for various
periods of time some for simple acts
such as taking a cigarette lighter on a
plane smoking on a train or failure to
pay fines lui who was an investigative
journalist in China he was listed as a
dishonest person for losing a defamation
lawsuit after he accused a high-ranking
politician of corruption after being
detained for almost a year
he lost his case and social standing
apart from restrictions in buying travel
tickets mr. leo has been banned from
buying property staying in luxury hotels
and even banned from sending his 9 year
old daughter to a private school if
people wish to improve their social
credit score they can participate in
pro-social activities such as helping
the elderly donating blood and
volunteering the program as it currently
stands is a pilot test and the specifics
may change in the full implementation
but interestingly according to a study
from the university of berlin a
distinguished german research university
approximately 80% of Internet connected
citizens in China approve of the system
this acceptance seems to me to be part
of Chinese culture many Chinese see the
system as less of an installment for
surveillance and more of a means to
encourage honesty good credit score's
gives citizens access to financial
support priority to schools and discount
some public tolls despite this a
monovalent underlines this program and
there is a large potential for abuse by
authorities it's not a stretch to
imagine the government using this tool
to exert more control over the
population as a whole looking at this
from a distance
xi Jinping appears to practice control
of the government in one hand and the
Chinese people in the other while
technology can be a tool for a more
transparent and open world this might
not be the case in China even the
internet at all around the world which
is used for sharing information and
knowledge is being suppressed in China
it is ranked worst in the world for
online freedom out of 65 countries
Western Iran Syria Cuba and Saudi Arabia
the censored Chinese internet restricts
the access of 800 million users
prominent sites that are blocked include
Google Facebook YouTube Twitter
Instagram whatsapp and The New York
Times the 2017 Harvard study estimates
the government uses social influences to
post 448 million pro-government comments
each year according to Bloomberg News
the Chinese government employs a hundred
thousand people to enforce censorship to
give you an idea how ridiculous this can
get even we neither poo was temporarily
censored after internet trolls compared
the fictional bear character to the
president of course there are ways to
get around these firewalls such as web
proxies and VPNs
however the average person may find it
difficult to figure out how to do this
safely and it's not a stretch of the
imagination to think that trying to
bypass the firewall could result in you
being publicly shamed and your photo
ending up on a public board or a decline
in your future social credit rating I'd
like to think that technology can bring
us closer and can actually be a great
benefit to society this is if it's used
for the right reasons but unfortunately
it's increasingly becoming a
double-edged sword surveillance and
control are two major pitfalls most
people watching this video are
Westerners from the outside looking in
and honestly what do we know about in
in Chinese culture I wasn't expecting so
many citizens to actually approve such
measures the Chinese government may
ultimately use this controls of
technology for good rather than evil but
for me personally molding a person's
behavior by use of force is something I
don't agree with and could have some
unintended consequences all along time
will tell but one thing is certain
technology is a very powerful tool with
surveillance and censorship becoming an
even greater issue with our governments
go down the same road for example very
recently in Australia where I live a
bill was passed by the Senate allowing
the government and security agencies to
have greater powers to get access to
encrypted messages of criminal suspects
in some cases they'll be able to mend
companies to build new capabilities to
allow them access
I've been flooded with messages on this
topic by fellow Australian so I think
I'll do a video on it soon on the same
node of technology going awry I do have
another video on the darker side of
social media and how it's negatively
affecting society I'll leave it in the
description ok so that just about wraps
up our look at China do you agree with
the reports of Chinese citizens saying
that this can be a good thing or do you
think so much monitoring and control is
ultimately leading down a bad road let
me know what you think in the comment
section below thanks for watching this
has been - go go you've been watching
cold fusion if you just stumbled across
this channel feel free to subscribe and
I'll see you again soon for the next
video
cheers guys
have a good one cold fusion its me
thinking